12 años después de dejar el cargo del
pueblo brasileño ofrecía a Luis Ignacio
alurada Silva un tercer mandatorio en su
discurso de historia al ex presidente
izquierdista y miembro del partido de
los trabajadores llamó a la paz y la
unidad y a la construcción de un nuevo
Brasil
[Aplausos]
histórico en este día histórico el 30 de
octubre la mayoría de los brasileños
dejó Claro que quiere más no menos
democracia
Brasil es mi prioridad la gente es mi
causa y luchar contra la miseria es para
lo que viviré hasta el final de mi vida
[Aplausos]
50,9% contra el
49,1% de los votos es la diferencia más
estrecha entre dos candidatos
presidenciales desde el retorno a la
democracia tras la dictadura militar por
lo tanto la tarea será difícil para
anular en este Brasil tan polarizado los
que votaron a la reelección del
ultradere
compartieron su decepción
sinceramente la victoria es cuando se
gana el no ganó le robaron la verdad es
que todo el mundo está decepcionado
os esperábamos por el tribunal supremo
que tenemos seguro que nos lo robaron
Pero sinceramente que podamos revertirlo
de alguna manera
después del anuncio de los resultados
los jefes de estado del mundo entero No
tardaron para felicitar a Lula el único
que todavía no se ha expresado es
precisamente el candidato ve